or would you guys like to hear a rapper
let's come to this this kind of if
you're in this wedge here what you want
to hear a rap about mermaid breeding Wow
that is I mean you've got some fans of
that hair down from mermaid breeding
that's an amazing suggestion cool you
set a high bar and people kind of in
this segment here what do I rap about
pesticides guys you killing it so far
last week here was like dildos and tits
but no no no what's a dildos and tits
tits and dildos cutting that or diver
mermaid breathing pesticides Wow are you
involved in pesticides in any way you
know how to talk about [ __ ] Monsanto in
the building pesticides mermaid breeding
so far these are great um from here to
here what you are at that return
policies oh yeah is there a particular
one that you're interested in because
some places have some baller return
policies might might choice that's so
kind of you but really defeats the
purpose of this whole audience
interaction segment Zappos Zappos is
that a shoe brand
yeah so it's a shoe what is their return
policy I've never ordered from Zappos
365 days Wow yeah yeah yeah yeah
and Rain Man in front it see it's a year
in the u.s. thank you for explaining
like slight talking like British people
don't know dates look we know dates
Americans you [ __ ] up the date you put
month first rather than day is stupid
should go day month year sending order
but then this is where right there's
only one day of the year you say day
month year fourth of July and that's
Independence Day like an ironic is [ __ ]
you can't leave our country and keep our
date my date
Zappos mermaid breeding pesticides
Zappos insurance return policy guys over
here what do i wrap that Donald Trump
get shout out all the time I'm afraid to
say I can't tear that suggestion go
tease yes amazing I'm just to clarify it
you mean the the chin furnishings yeah
ooh thank you
but yeah I do not not find a go tease
okay cool cool go tease go tease guys
over here you you have the the privilege
of the final suggestion what was it
gonna be answering machine yeah you were
prepped for that that was good just
stand straight casual as well just chill
on hun just answering machine yeah I got
this okay so mermaid breeding pesticides
Zappos return policy
answering machine go tease yeah how
could I forget that
okay this then lovely people the Comedy
Cellar to close out with some real
panache and pizzazz some one of those
went oh my god did you think I was gonna
do all that and be like well good night
no no I'm living my dream [ __ ]
this is we've got a sold-out show we can
lock the door it's gonna be a wrap it's
gonna be a freestyle rap as a rap made
up on the spot based entirely on those
suggestions is not rig it is not
prepared and do not worry
it will not be as [ __ ] as you might
expect it to be if we could drop that
beat let's show how we do I'm gonna roll
up my sleeves slightly can we drop down
pump it should have done a soundcheck
really that's what Kanye would have done
well we built up that energy and it's
real gonna be good it's gonna be orchid
if you locked my iPhone and I don't have
to be let me like hit the number zero
zero zero say it's not that it's
actually three sixty five which is a
year and also that Rain Man Joe come
here before I hope you don't it's locked
okay trying to figure out what it is
yes that's [ __ ] look right I know I said
that right my joke earlier but like it's
not that yeah some C natural rap mofos
oh the rat pack that would be good
wouldn't it I just I want it before we
start um I made that joke about Rain Man
I don't want to seem offense tone with
Asperger's my brother has Asperger's
sorry the very intelligent man if you
give a Rubik's Cube takes my twelve
seconds to say thank you see you
wouldn't go that joke if the rapid odd
on time would you right let's remind
ourselves while the rap is about it's
about mermaid breathing pesticides
opposed return policy go tease an
answering machine let's do this let's
hope it's ready let's drop that beat and
let's show them how we do
it's gonna be real good when it happens
it's coming real good
you want me to know that should we pay
ha ha feels like this going on for a
long time it won't play piano
oh we got the other side the other sound
game ok wow this is really it's it's not
as good as this buildup is making it
that's the problem but we don't that
makes it sound like it's the same
suggestions here
it sounds like I'm just paying all these
[ __ ] to say the same words over
and over again
it sucks thing is that Asperges ones
probably my best joke so I can't really
can we top that now I'm taking a break
from karate lessons it's a
[Music]
I like a fine pitch with a next plate
for this one got a fin in the tail of
mermaid no vagina so no minstrel
bleeding how the [ __ ] are these mermaid
divas breathing they may be ballroom
I've never dissected one that must
assume the Merman tongues over yeah
we've all seen mr. Godsey but man no
penis maybe they just rub it together
the fish scales the attention like see
there we go and keep Triton that's
mermaid infant is not nice one
no let Satan keep the lord of disease I
like to go to my lord you can no see I
go there I keep the weeds outside
because I like to draw with the
pesticide
just return the phone longer 365 days a
year
that's a - wrong
leave a message of the Jeep by the Queen
my son he's the Prince of Wales
I always know I'm always so aware of my
voice self-aware when I leave the house
going messages I try and wrap trying
keep it flowing but people's going up
and it makes them weak and so I just say
my prison
[Music]